in today's video
nothing
no i'm just kidding i swear there will
be no more nothing puns for the entire
rest of this video but in all
seriousness today i get to do something
i don't get to do very often which is
review a new phone
from a new company
so this is the nothing phone one
[Music]
so on one hand this is a new phone from
a new phone company but on the other
hand you pretty quickly realize there's
a lot of stuff here that we've seen
before it's a company from carl pay
former chief of oneplus running the hype
playbook we've seen before of slowly
revealing more and more info about a
phone to drum up interest but what's new
and interesting about this phone is what
they've chosen as their differentiating
feature so like i said in the
impressions video if you're a new
company coming along you have to give
people a reason to choose it over the
boring established ones that most people
buy and so oneplus in the past would
sort of lean on exceptional specs for a
low price that was the thing that you
could count on from a oneplus phone to
stand out
with nothing
its design now i have a lot of thoughts
and feelings about this design after
using it for the past week there's both
a dark and a light version of the
nothing phone as you can see they both
have flat aluminum sides all the way
around the strategically placed antenna
lines power button on the right volume
on the left and then the back is the
signature transparent gorilla glass with
a design underneath it it is a pretty
simple design but it is just nuanced and
complex enough to appreciate it it has
some depth you know it has indicators
for certain pieces inside the phone like
the wireless charging coil it has
exposed screws it has written text on
the back and most importantly it has the
900 plus leds organized in these
diffused strips all around the back of
the phone with the unique functionality
that i'll get to in a second but overall
with all of this together i think it's
safe to say i've never
seen a phone that looks quite like this
before so as far as standing out from
the pack with a unique design well
mission accomplished but at the same
time if you squint
it does kinda look like an iphone still
you know with the flat sides and the
dual camera placement it has the shape
of an iphone matter of fact this well
this is an iphone with the brand's new
something skin applied to it uh and
short of lighting up the leds it
basically accomplishes 90 of the same
look from the different shading of the
white color to the red recording light
to the faithful indicator of where the
wireless charger is supposed to be in
whatever phone you skin all the way to
the text on the corner that's just a
very well considered easter egg i guess
that's why they're a channel sponsor
well done guys i'll link it below but
the lights are what's really
unique here as you can see the the glyph
interface
so not only do they look quite unique
but they also serve a purpose they
actually have a function to them
at least they're supposed to so there's
one light up around the cameras one at
the top right corner
one big one all the way around the
wireless charging coil in the middle
then an exclamation point at the bottom
so for getting a phone call the lights
all just light up and sync with whatever
ringtone you have sweet the exclamation
mark at the bottom will also light up to
indicate your charge status and then it
can show you again with a convenient
little bump i definitely like that a lot
and then it'll also light up when you
talk to google assistant so if you say
hey hot word what's the weather tomorrow
you can see it lights up with a little
feedback as you're talking then it reads
you your answer out loud it's basically
the defining feature of this phone in
the dark or the light i actually think
it looks better in the dark now that
i've seen it but it's it's huge for this
phone they also made a transparent case
to be able to see it all the time now
here's the thing all of these require
you to have your phone out on your desk
and face down
which is cool but for me personally i
typically have my phone in my pocket or
even if i don't i'll have it on my desk
but it'll be face up
and even if it is on my desk and face up
i also typically have it on silent so
now that i'm using this phone i'm like
oh i got to make a conscious effort to
make sure i remember to put my phone
face down more often just don't put it
down on some some grit or some sand or
anything and scratch the screen but it's
the nothing phone like that's the whole
point i gotta use it but even then i
still find myself just flipping over the
phone to check my notifications because
i don't get that many calls and most of
the time it's just a single blinking
light at the bottom
and i don't know what that means like i
wish there was more granularity in what
the settings could let me choose the led
lights to do like i remember back in the
day phones used to have rgb notification
lights so i knew that a yellow
notification light meant i have a new
tweetdeck notification or a new blue one
is a new email or a new green one as a
new text message with this one it's all
white leds so it would be cool if in the
settings i could set a certain dot
pattern to mean a notification from a
certain app like that basically seems
like the whole point of these lights
best case scenario it can communicate
with you without you having to pick it
up but as of right now really your only
options are to change the brightness and
then to turn certain light features
on or off i don't know based on the
light flashing what type of notification
i have what app it's from who's trying
to contact me nothing i kind of assumed
i would be able to do that and i
wouldn't put it past them to enable that
with some sort of software update but
like i always say buy a phone for what
it is now not what it's promised to be
so yeah as of right now that's not real
now there were some other questions
about the lights some people were
wondering if they took a lot of battery
power nope they don't if you leave them
literally on all the time for an hour
straight they'll take maybe two to three
percent of your battery so it's almost
nothing and then the other thing was
people were wondering about maybe some
slight discoloration between the leds
because as it turns out getting a bunch
of different small cheap white leds to
all be the exact same color temperature
is actually pretty difficult now i have
noticed that the top left light around
my camera is slightly more green than
the rest of mine but not enough to
bother me or make any difference in the
way i use it and the lights do actually
get bright enough to use as a fill light
that's one of the features and so in in
really dark places really with a very
close-up subject i can actually say that
it is better to use than a normal flash
but anyway now that you know about the
aesthetic i can actually talk to you
about using the actual phone and i think
the good place to start with that would
be
the price
and the price is starting at 399
great british pounds so
that's the baseline price for this phone
and it behaves
exactly as you'd expect from a mid-range
android phone in 2022. and when i say
that i mean that as a compliment there
are some really good phones in this
price range where it's kind of hard to
go wrong with the top options here the
pixel 6as the galaxy a53s of the world
and the nothing phone fits right in
alongside those so it's really good it
has a snapdragon 778g plus and it runs
android very close to stock
i would keep in mind the base price has
just 128 gigs of storage and that model
only comes in black but the version i'm
testing which has 256 gigs of storage
and 12 gigs of ram is 499 pounds but it
has performed
very well big time shout out to this
display not only is it a pretty big flat
6.55 inch 1080p oled with pretty good
brightness up to 1200 nits and not only
does it have an under display
fingerprint reader that doesn't suck and
a corner hole punch with a selfie camera
and not only does it have perfectly even
bezels all the way around which is a
pretty notably more expensive thing to
achieve since we've got to use a
flexible oled display
but it also
has a high refresh rate now it's not
ltpo but it will dynamically bump
between 120 hertz and 60 hertz depending
on what you're doing and it has a 240hz
touch sample rate so it is very
responsive and smooth especially in just
regular day-to-day stuff it can drop
some frames when you're doing some more
heavy stuff some gaming when there's
just a lot more going on and that's
understandable this isn't you know a
super high end power hungry chip so
there's going to be some trade-offs but
it definitely helps that this software
nothing os
is mostly very close to stock android
with just a few of their light touches
on top
lots of those touches are aesthetic
and animations like they have their own
fonts with this dot matrix style this
nice extra custom animation when you
pull open a folder on the home screen or
pull down the quick settings and they
have a couple extra home screen widgets
they've tossed in and to me it looks
like the only stock app that they've
touched that they've skimmed
are the camera and this voice recorder
app which also has the dot matrix theme
going on
and they say it's gonna also be able to
add this tesla car control feature which
kind of lit my eyes up like oh that's
what i would be able to use but right
now it's in the experimental features
section and even though i'm signed into
the normal tesla app every time i try it
it just keeps saying no cars found in
your account so it doesn't work yet but
apparently that's supposed to let you
put some vehicle controls up in those
quick settings like a door unlock or
flashing the lights or something when
they get that working but you know for
now don't count on it i think basically
i'm just happy there's no bloatware like
it's just a very clean
reasonable
refined android experience and i think
part of that is that it's not arriving
on us carriers so you might have seen
the headlines this phone's not destined
for the us at least not right now but i
also am having no problem using it on
att doesn't get 5g but i've had no
problems with getting 4g everywhere but
it basically feels like a tweaked pixel
which is a compliment i like it and then
the rest of the phone across the board
is uh
pretty
middle of the road pretty mid-range like
i said it's not really flexing with the
specs so these are some pretty modest
ones across the board here there's a 4
500 milliamp hour battery inside which i
was comfortably getting all day battery
life with so that was nice it was a
solid five to six hours of screen on
time which for my use is a b plus and
the charging speeds were yeah pretty
modest 15 watts wireless charging and 33
watts wire charging which will get you
half battery in half an hour it's not
bad
the haptics are solid definitely not bad
but not notably amazing or anything i
like them but the speakers are pretty
forgettable technically they're a stereo
pair with that earpiece up top but the
earpiece is not doing much work and
blocking the bottom speaker pretty much
mutes the phone and it's only ip53 water
resistant which means no dunking or
splashing or wiping down the phone like
you might be able to with an ip68 phone
it's just one of the short places they
save some money and the cameras
typically this is the thing where you
separate the mid tier from the flagship
pretty quickly and i don't know if it's
just because i just finished testing one
of the absolute best smartphone cameras
in the world but the nothing phones
cameras were particularly
average so there's a pair of 50
megapixel cameras on the back here with
the primary having ois and at f 1.8 and
with 114 degree ultra wide i think some
people might go into this with high
hopes based on the hype but they'll
pretty quickly adjust because again this
is a 400 phone okay so if i give it good
light and good enough conditions i can
get some decent shots nothing to write
home about but acceptable photos which
is good but as soon as you have anything
less than a ton of light the photos very
rapidly deteriorate mostly just adding a
bunch of noise and the shutter speed
going way up getting way slower so you
can pretty much forget about taking
pictures of moving objects in anything
other than direct sunlight for context
though just so you know the main sensor
is the sony imx 766 which we just saw in
the rog phone 6 i reviewed and it's also
in phones like the oneplus nord 2t
so
set your expectations right and you
won't be that disappointed but if you're
hoping for some type of flagship killer
camera this is definitely not it but hey
on the sustainability note the nothing
phone is made from 100 recycled aluminum
these rails and also an impressive 50
plus percent of the plastics inside are
made from bio-based and recycled sources
also the box that came in is very thin
and small which of course is too small
to include a charging brick but it is
fully recyclable paper and cardboard so
i can appreciate that basically i'm
overall happy to report that the nothing
phone one doesn't feel like
cheap corner cutting
as much as that does feel like they set
out to make a phone that hits a certain
price point and then separate it from
the pack by being a good user experience
but also having a unique cool
interesting aesthetic i think that's
really smart so i think the bigger
picture now is okay they're they're
working on an ecosystem
around this thing this new nothing
company they started with the earbuds
which were not the most amazing sound or
performance in the world but had a very
solid user experience and a very
distinctive design
and then they moved on to a phone which
didn't have the most amazing performance
or specs in the world but had a really
solid user experience and a really
distinctive design
so what's next is it going to be a
tablet
a smart speaker i don't know it could be
anything but whatever it is i think we
can safely expect it to not be super
focused on performance and specs
but to just have a solid user experience
and a distinctive design that's what
they're going to lean into that's smart
and i like it so even if it might not be
for me someone who's pixel peeping and
is particularly concerned about
performance on the highest end i do like
that we're still getting cool looking
stuff that i just gotta say that
more cool looking stuff please in the
world of not as cool looking stuff it
was nice it's dope
either way that's been it
there is nothing left to talk about
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]